تحولات تشهدها اتجاهات الاستهلاك في رمضان
هذا العام في السوق الاماراتي من المتوقع
ان يزداد التسوق عبر الانترنت والمزيد من
المدفوعات الرقميه بحسب موقع عادت زياره
متاجر البقاله عبر الانترنت ارتفع في
سبتمبر 2022 بنسبه 28% مقارنه من سبتمبر
2019 وهذا مؤشر مهم على سلوك المستهلك
المتوقع في رمضان عام 2023
خلال رمضان 2022 حققت مشتريات تطبيقات
التسوق في رمضان نموا بالنسبه 64% ومن
المتوقع ان يحافظ رمضان 2023 على نفس
النمو مع تحول المزيد من المستهلكين نحو
الطلب عبر الانترنت في الامارات ايضا
وبحسب شركه اتش ال بي يتناول 46% الافطار
خارج المنزل مره واحده على الاقل اسبوعيا
وسته وعشرون بالمئه يستخدمون خدمات
التوصيل خاصه في النصف الثاني من رمضان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]